follow Lange focus on Facebook Twitter
and Instagram hello everyone welcome to
the Lange focused Channel and my name is
Paul today's topic is the Malay language
or bahasa melayu as it's called in Malay
people outside of Southeast Asia may not
be very familiar with Malay but if we
include all speakers of all varieties of
Malay it is one of the top 10 most
widely spoken languages in the world
and when I say widely I mean by a large
number of people it has around 77
million native speakers and around 173
million second language speakers for a
total of about 250 million speakers of
course different sources give different
numbers but something like that it's
spoken in Malaysia where it has around
eighteen point five million native
speakers out of a population of around
32 million people
Malaysia is an ethnically and
linguistically diverse place with large
communities of people speaking Chinese
and Indian languages as well as numerous
indigenous minority languages everyone
in Malaysia now learns Malay at school
but some speakers of other languages
either aren't fluent in Malay or they
choose not to speak it very much after
they graduate from school Singapore is
another ethnically diverse place where
Malays are a minority the malay language
is spoken by around 700,000 people there
or 13% of the population it is also
spoken by around two hundred and
sixty-six thousand people or about 64%
of the population of brunei what up it's
not Brunei in Brunei idiot oh yeah it's
sorry in English we say Brunei oh my god
you slaughtered the word Brunei okay
Brunei so like I was saying it's spoken
by around two hundred and sixty six
thousand people or 64% of the population
of Brunei it is also spoken by around 1
million people in southern Thailand
adjacent to Peninsular Malaysia and
Malaya spoken by around 11.23 million
people in Indonesia but that's only part
of the story there are also about 43
million native speakers of bahasa
indonesia and around 155 second language
speakers of bahasa indonesia
so what's bahasa indonesia well when
speaking of the malay language we need
to distinguish between malay dialects
which vary from place to place and the
standardized forms of the language the
first standardized form of the line
which is bahasa melayu which is used in
Malaysia Brunei and Singapore and
functions as an umbrella language for
all of the Malay dialects that are
spoken there
the second standardized form of the
language is bahasa indonesia and is used
in indonesia and functions as a lingua
franca between speakers of different
languages because there are hundreds of
languages in indonesia i plan to focus
specifically on indonesian in a
different video in the future this is
interesting in Malaysia the official
name of Malay is bahasa malaysia meaning
the language of malaysia
instead of bahasa melayu which means the
language of the Malays this name was
chosen to show that the language is a
language for all Malaysian citizens and
not only for ethnic Malays but some
people want to change the name back to
bahasa melayu history Malay is the most
widely spoken language in the
Austronesian language family the
Austronesian languages can most likely
be traced back to a common ancestor
proto Austronesian in what is now Taiwan
around five thousand two hundred years
ago various dialects arose from proto
Austronesian one of them being proto
malayo-polynesian which began splitting
up into various languages around 4000
years ago as Austronesian people
expanded to the South from Taiwan
the Millea polynesian sub branch
includes most of the Austronesian
languages outside of taiwan a proto
maleic language the ancestor of all
Malay dialects probably originated on
the island of Borneo more than 2,000
years ago before it speakers migrated
West to Sumatra
and the Malay Peninsula old Malay the
beginning of the Common Era and by that
I mean after the year 1 ce e or 1 AD
same thing by the way was a time of
great Indian influence in the region and
during this time old Malay emerged it
was highly influenced by Sanskrit and
written in Indian scripts like a lava
the oldest known inscriptions of old
Malay are the key to kombucha which were
found in Sumatra and date back to the
7th century CE the oldest old Malay
manuscript that still exists today is
the Tang Jun Tana a legal text from the
14th century still before Islam was
widespread in the area classical Malay
Islam soon became dominant in the area
and trade with the Muslim world
increased resulting in a lot of Arabic
and Persian vocabulary entering the
language and resulting in the adoption
of the joeys script Joey is a version of
the Arabic script that was modified to
suit the Malay language during the
Malacca Sultanate which was like a
kingdom and its successes the johor
Sultanate Malay became wide
used as a lingua franca during this time
Islamic literature greatly affected the
language with more Arabic and Persian
vocabulary entering Malay and because
Malacca was a busy international port
with people from various countries Malay
also absorbed vocabulary from different
languages like Tamil and Chinese
languages during this classical Malay
period Malay evolved into something
relatively similar to the bahasa melayu
and bahasa indonesia of today there were
actually two forms of Malay that became
widespread during this time period first
there was the formal classical Malay
which was the state language and the
language of courts and literature and
there was bizarre Malay or Malay you
Posada a low language spoken by traders
as a lingua franca throughout the
archipelago bizarre Malay is thought to
have been a pidgin language featuring
vocabulary from Malay but influenced by
other languages such as Chinese
languages and there were also local
Malay dialects that varied from place to
place pre-modern Malay in the 19th
century European colonial powers were
dominating the region with the Dutch in
Indonesia and the British in Malaysia
during this time period improvements to
the printing press made Malay books and
newspapers more widely available to the
common people so that literary Malay or
classical Malay was no longer just the
language of the courts in the elite the
literary Malay of the Malacca and the
johor Sultanate in other words classical
Malay was recognized by the British and
by the Dutch as the standard form of the
language and became the language of
Education one notable change during the
colonial period was the adoption of the
Rumi writing system the use of Roman
characters to write Malay instead of the
Joey script and English loanwords began
to trickle into Malay in the areas under
British control modern malay the
abundance of malay literature in the
19th century sparked new enthusiasm for
the language and Malay linguists began
their efforts to standardize and
modernize the language in 1936 the Malay
scholars Abba published a series of
books called pilita bahasa in which he
updated the grammar of classical Malay
forming the basis of bahasa melayu and
bahasa indonesia in both malaysia and
indonesia the standard form of Malay
became an important part of their
respective nationalist movements and
their struggles for independence when
Indonesia declared independence in 1945
bahasa indonesia became the national
language and when malaysia became
independent in
19:57 bahasa melayu became the national
language dialects bahasa melayu is the
standard form of Malay used in Malaysia
in Singapore and in Brunei and it's the
form of the language taught in schools
but there are numerous spoken dialects
of Malay that vary not only from country
to country but also from state to state
and from town to town with differences
in pronunciation and vocabulary the
Malay spoken in Sabah and Sarawak tends
to be more similar to that spoken in
Brunei and Singapore but different from
the dialects in West Malaysia in some
states in West Malaysia are known for
being quite divergent for example the
dialects of Kelantan Kelantan borders
Thailand to the north were a similar
dialect is spoken the difference is that
in Kelantan everyone learned standard
Malay at school but in southern Thailand
everyone learns Thai at school this
makes cross dialect communication harder
for speakers of Malaya and Thailand but
for speakers of other Malay dialects
standard Malay is a unifying force and
speaking a little more formally can help
people bridge communication gaps
standard Malaya's also the form of Malay
learned by non Malays at school so
standard Malaya sometimes the language
of inter-ethnic communication though
some people choose to speak English
instead so what is Malay like like most
Austronesian languages Malay is not a
tonal language it has simple phonology
and every written character represents
only one sound in most cases it has a
simple SVO sentence structure for
example I am MacIntyre meaning I eat
vegetables kaya
Mac and again I don't eat meat now let's
add a modal verb saya anomic and again I
don't want to eat meat Chaya dynamic and
again a dominant Susu I don't want to
eat meat or drink milk Malaya grammar is
simple first of all there's no
grammatical gender there are also no
noun cases
there is also no plural form in Malay if
you want to make a plural explicit you
reduplicate the word or repeat the word
orang means a person or animal RAM means
people and speaking of or on fun fact
orang means person in Malay Hooten means
forest in Malay or on Putin means forest
person also known as orangutan cool if
you want to modify a noun
you add the modifying word after the
noun the word for book buku now let's
add a demonstrative pronoun fukui to
that book or with a possessive pronoun
booboo hiya my book or buku buku thea my
books or with an adjective buku Mahon an
expensive book in malay there is no
copula verb to be at least in regular
speech and there is no definite or
indefinite article so lucuma hon could
also mean the book is expensive but to
be more clear you might say Luke we do
my prepositions in Malay are very
straightforward and intuitive say abre
so dari Canada I come from Canada diana
rigg iike by that malam I want to go to
the night market my dad give gun dope
and I gather there is a discount for
students in this sentence other means
there is one of the things that makes
learning Malay fun is that there are no
verb conjugations the form of the verb
stays exactly the same regardless of
whether as in present tense past tense
or future tense so we have the verb
meaning to eat in present tense makan in
past tense makan in future tense makan
the tense is determined by specifying a
time period like BM Kamandi he will eat
later or by using an adverb before the
verb iya at kaimakan
he will eat dia - damn can he already
ate or the haedong can he is currently
eating or he's eating now and there are
some other adverbs like this but of
course it's not quite that simple
because we have the verb mankind to eat
but we also have the verb be mankind to
be eaten and there mankind to be eaten
accidentally and we have the verb
mankind to consume then we have mama can
can to feed something to someone
these are examples of one of Malaya
most challenging features for learners
its system of building words from roots
and affixes up above we created some new
verbs but we can also create other types
of words mckennon food the Macan someone
who eats so Burma Cadogan means a
meat-eater Malay makes extensive use of
this kind of a fixation let's look at
one more example using the root word a
Giada which means to teach I get in
teachings Balika to learn man I get to
teach be again to be taught intransitive
as in I'm being taught be a gherkin
transitive as in the lesson is being
taught mumble I guarantee to study deep
alighieri
to be studied Peleg a student bonaga
teacher bumble a Garin learning burble a
Garin to be educated
all of these affixes might seem
overwhelming at first but they're fairly
systematic and once you get used to the
function of all of the different a fixes
then it helps you to understand words
that you've never heard before and it
helps you to guess how to say words that
you don't know yet standard Malay is a
very user-friendly language for learners
especially if you're used to learning
more complex languages the biggest
challenge that you'll likely face is the
difference between the formal language
and the casual language and the
dialectal variation that you'll
encounter especially different
pronunciation but by learning the
standard polite form of Malay you form a
good basis for communication and you can
learn the more colloquial style of
communication as you go stay tuned for a
future episode in which I cover bahasa
indonesia and i'll focus in on that form
of malay specifically be sure to
subscribe to line focus and follow Leng
focus on Facebook Twitter and Instagram
and I'd like to say thank you to all of
my patreon supporters especially the
ones on the screen right now for their
generous support every month thank you
for watching and have a nice day
[Music]
by the way ahaha means language